[Music]
I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv vales contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the
one parents this is a podcast you're
going to want to listen to from
beginning to the end as a parent for
myself and Tom two girls I got two boys
two girls uh it's an issue that bothers
me I don't like it I'm in a position
where I can make some noise and make
some push uh uh my weight around but
sometimes people don't this is more
about a podcast we're doing for parents
that sometimes feel helpless but we want
to give you resources to not feel
helpless and hear different stories and
have your kids uh who are possibly being
manipulated or brainwashed and to think
in some way to see stories of others who
went through it and what they did about
it and how they're going through you
know their own set of challenges so
today's guests um today's guest we have
three folks here with us one we have oi
London who flew out from London uh is a
British YouTuber who publicly identified
as a non-binary and began transitioning
from male to female in 2018 before
reverting back to male in 2022 he's got
a book that just came out as well called
gender Madness you can order that ol's
here with us thank you ollie for being
with us thanks a pleasure and then we
have Luca Hine who is a d transitioner
who underwent a double masectomy at age
16 at 21 Luca sued her doctors for the
rushed procedure becoming the fifth
person in us to pursue legal action for
Hasty gender affirming treatment thank
you so much for being on of course and
then last but not least Aaron Friday who
is an American lawyer and activist who's
the parent of of a formerly gender
confused child Aaron Advocates fighting
for children adults and the
transitioners struggling with gender
identity and gender expression Erin
thank you for being on thank you for
having me of course and uh gang while
we're going through this yeah I just
want you to kind of pay attention to
this data here tell me if this concerns
you at all because it does to me uh in
2019 do in the US the hormone
replacement therapy Market size was
ready $10.2 billion that's in 2019 we
don't know what it is in 2024 uh what
it'll be what it'll be in 2023 it's
telling us it grows at an rate of
6.1% and the male to female gender
reassignment surgery segment alone was
valued at85 million in 2019 there's a
lot of money involved in this there's a
lot of things being speculated on why
this is taking place this is the US sex
reassignment surgery Market it's an
industry a full-blown industry if you're
looking at something that'll give you a
good rate of return turn it looks like
this could do that for you because the
media many schools are behind it this is
a collective effort of them trying to
confuse your kids and it's important for
you to be involved so you can help your
kids while they're going through this
messy facee having said that let's get
right into it Aon would you mind
starting off sharing a bit of your
background how you got into the space as
a lawyer yourself you live in San
Francisco San Francisco's already got a
lot of crazy things going on targeting
you know uh uh what new's going through
with Califoria is going through what the
streets are looking like and on top of
that something like this so if you don't
mind sharing your background with the
audience that'd be great sure so um I'm
a Democrat of 37 years which is going to
shock your
audience and um you know my daughter
came home from seventh grade she and all
of her friends uh from sex ed class and
they all decided that they were
something on the alphabet none of them
picked a white girl who likes boys um
because that would make them oppress
professors and that was the first
opening to me of some that something's
going on at our schools and I was quite
shocked because I was a volunteer at the
school so I knew all these teachers by a
first uh name basis and you know fast
forward all of these uh kids including
my kid went from you know pansexual
polyamorous non-binary and then lesbian
and then landed on trans and trans seems
to stick and that's how um I got
involved and I decided that once once I
got my daughter stable that it was my
duty to save other kids and to make sure
that no other parent went through what
we went through OE how about yourself um
so I struggled with identity for a
number of years since my teenage years I
used to get bullied a lot and I had a
very bad relationship with my father so
I kind of became very feminine and I was
always told you know you're more like a
girl you're you know I was never treated
as a boy I was never sporty so um as I
became an adult I started undergoing
surgeries and I kind of became addicted
to that because it was the feeling of
validation and feeling better about
yourself every time you do something and
you know I ended up having 32 surgeries
in total I had 11 facial feminization
surgeries in one day and you know it
would give me a temporary fix just like
most people that are transitioning or
changing these days you feel great for a
couple of months because you get that
validation you get positive
reinforcements and then I got to that
point where I was like where am I going
with this I'm getting more and more
unhappy it's making my relationship with
my mother very bad it's it's it was such
a tough situation and then actually
started going to church because I needed
an outlet to try and uh you know find
myself and get some peace of mind and
you know since then I've been you know
waking up to what's going on and trying
to be an advocate for all these
kids very interesting story how about
yourself um so I was someone who was
going going through a lot as a young
teenager that that might be an
understatement of everything going on
but um and kind of found that like the
transit entity seemed to be like a fix
for all my problems essentially it was
presented to me as oh you're not
uncomfortable because of X Y or Z
happening in your life you're not
dealing with trauma uh you don't hate
your period because you're just you know
like a teenage girl uh you are a boy
that's just born in the wrong body and
that ended with me the very first uh
medical intervention I ever had being a
double myectomy at 16 then a few months
later I was put on hormones and then at
20 I transitioned C can you give me the
speed of you know I'm having these
thoughts and this is what I want to do
Mom Dad can I see the doctor this is
where you're at I think after like 52
minutes or whatever they said here's
what and then here's the first surgery
what was that timeline like so my
freshman year of high school I actually
came out as transgender in a what is
called a partial hospitalization program
which is like a step down from inpatient
so it is essentially an intensive
Therapy Program I came out as
transgender there and then my parents
were told okay well we're going to we
need to tell you about this cuz there's
a perceived suicide risk there uh so you
need to know and then from there I went
to a gender affirming therapist as in a
specific therapist who specializes in uh
quote unquote gender diverse young
people um and of course you know the
minute the minute I walked in there it
was affirmation only we are there's no
really working through this it's just
you you're what's the next step in
transition essentially
and I saw her for about a year um cuz I
would have been let's see 15 yeah 15 at
the time and then
when I so the summer when I was 16 that
is when I had
surgery the summer when you were 16 is
when you had surgery so so from the
moment you saw the doctor how much
longer after the surgery happened um so
the surgeon the surgeon that we saw who
was kind of associated with the gender
Clinic cuz my therap IST was actually
like she worked with the gender Clinic
itself so she was not a neutral Party by
any means got it um and so essentially
why they went to chest surgery first is
I was like okay well I'm really
uncomfortable with my chest and so they
were like okay this can this will will
tackle the biggest issue first um and so
I saw the surgeon briefly once in March
of that year and that was initially CU I
was going to have surgery over my high
school spring break and then we were
like okay that that's not enough time to
recover and go back to like carrying a
backpack around and so that got moved to
the summer but essentially before
surgery I only saw the surgeon like
twice um I believe there was some sort
of like phone consultation with my
parents but um aside from that it was
just like the initial consultation and
then the appointment before surgery what
was a language right like like what what
I want to know is if I'm a parent and I
got a say I got a 8-year-old girl I'm
like okay I got to be prepared for this
I can't can't afford to put my kids into
private school I'm going to public
school and maybe I'm in California I
never want to leave I'm in New York I'm
in Illinois I'm in one of these weird
States and what is the structure that
they put fear in Mom and Dad if you
don't do this she could commit suicide
was it more we're going to help you this
is what we're going to do there's
solutions for this you know you are
categorically falling into what language
did you see them use so it is a it is
very much a mix of both uh you hear you
hear lines thrown around a lot like
would you rather have a dead daughter or
a living son would doctors saying this
yeah medical professionals will say this
you have would you rather have a dead
daughter or living son uh would you
rather be planning a transition or a
funeral um and they will tell this to
parents who are desperate W seriously
they are desperate and then to the kids
of course it is one you're instill
already instilling that fear of suicide
because we know suicide has a social
contagion factor and when you tell
vulnerable young people that like if you
you know this is your only way way out
and if you don't get that the your other
option is essentially suicide it lives
in your head I was never a suicide risk
um before I transitioned and throughout
my trans transition I wasn't really a
suicide risk either um except even then
I still had that thought in the back of
my head of like okay well I've had
surgery and I'm not suicidal now but
like if I if I don't go on to the next
step of transition will I be and so it
is a driving factor and it comes from a
place of fear and then you have the
other half of it which is essentially
the love bombing and affirmation from
the community and these same medical
professionals I telling you okay well
now you found you found your true self
you are you know this is who you're
always meant to be um and essentially
just going through and being like you're
valid you are loved your parents don't
understand you but we do and we're here
to listen and we're here to help you um
all while driving that wedge in between
a parent and a child when when a child
is going something through like going
through something like this they need
their their parents close and they need
to be building that relationship and a
great sign that this is not a like
necessarily kind and is almostly
predatory action is the fact that if it
was really you know such a suicide risk
if it was really such a present thing
you would want these parents involved as
much as possible and you would be
building that relationship of Love
instead of breaking down that trust did
did Tik Tok have anything to do with it
or no because you're you you're born in
2002 mhm so you're 21 right so Tik Tok
is still a thing in your life at the
time if you're 16 I don't know if Tik
Tok was I I believe it was called
musically at the time musically yes um I
was never on that uh I watched a lot of
YouTube okay um YouTube and Instagram I
was never people like to point to Tumblr
I was never on Tumblr um really really
just that and also just like finding out
about this stuff because I I will say I
found out about a lot of this stuff
because it came into prominence
kind of um right when right after gay
marriage was legalized um and then all
of a sudden the tone shifted and all
these other words were coming up and so
of course you know I was in like Junior
High when gay marriage was legalized and
it was you know that was kind of a lot
of uh people my age is first especially
if you Liv a little bit more sheltered
or you're like in a little bit smaller
school that was like the first
introduction to the LGBT community and
of course it was you know presented as
like oh well love is love all all this
all this stuff you know um and then
after that was legalized there was a
like firm tone shift from you know gay
adults doing what they want and getting
married like that all of a sudden to the
trans stuff there's right to the trans
stuff um and the the theory about that
is that all these all these like
activist organizations once gay marriage
was legalized they didn't have anything
else to fight for so they sh to the
trans stuff um and that is where you
started hearing terms terms like
non-binary uh transgender and those were
being more more heavily introduced into
the mainstream for people my age on all
sorts of social media I want to Erin I
want to come to you because and thank
you for that but I want to come to you
because for you you know you're
listening to this and I watch the way
when you do interviews you're you're
you're a lawyer so naturally you're
watching to find leaks in the
opposition's argument and you're trying
to see what their approach is what their
tactic is what they're doing you've gone
through this from the parents
perspective okay she's gone through this
as the child perspective
and all he's gone through in a complete
different perspective right for you from
the parents perspective what what caused
you to all of a sudden get a little bit
more concerned and
involved well as soon as my daughter
came out as trans that was the ultimate
concern and also overhearing the school
calling her by a different name and a
different pronoun without involving the
parent I mean that was red flag red flag
um and you know I understand what Luca's
parents went through because I went
through it we went to different
psychologists different psychiatrists
different doctors every single one of
them told me to affirm my child I even
had a psychiatrist tell me that my
memory of my daughter being this girly
girl from age you know baby to the age
of 13 was a false memory it was so
absurd to me um I was given the uh
suicide stats to
41% and then I would I would queer these
you know medical providers so-called
experts and I'd say well tell me a
little bit more about the study how many
people were in that study what questions
were asked not one of them can answer
the question because no one had read the
study well I had I had read read the
study and I found them all to be flimsy
as all get out um but yeah I mean the
the pressure on the parents I was also
told my daughter would commit suicide um
my daughter actually told me that she
would commit suicide because all trans
kids commit suicide so the fear of the
parent is is real and you you have no
one to turn to to help you you do this
alone so I understand when parents
capitulate because it's really a tough
Journey as a parent because everyone
hates you the teachers hate you I had
Child Protective Services come to my
house for not affirming my child I had
the police come to my house I have lost
what are you talking about you the
police and child protective services
comes to your house in California what
are they telling you when they come to
your house so this is how it went down
so um after you know this is co so my
daughter's down the hallway from me and
I hear them calling her a male name and
using male pronouns so I call the school
and I read them the riot act I mean I
lay into to them hard um about they have
no right to change my my daughter's name
uh and they saidwell we need to be a
safe
space safe space she's down the hall for
me she never stepped foot into that
school it's co this is you know freshman
year of high school I asked them tell me
one thing about my daughter is she tall
is she fat what color is her hair they
knew nothing about her wow nothing about
her let me while you're going through
this like I'm trying to think uh you and
your husband are you guys married at the
time are you guys together at the time
are you on the same page of what you are
not for and what you are for politically
as well as with what to do with your
kids we are totally on the same page at
the time yes so you've always been on
the same page correct got it so it's not
like a you know cuz sometimes these
types of things like you heard about
Dwayne Wade and his wife right where
Dwayne Wade Miami local he moves to
California because he feels safer for
his kid transitioning but the mom's like
what are you doing let's wait till 18
years old so sometimes in these types of
situations mom and dad are not on the
same page so there's a leak to come in
between kind of similar maybe for you
know oi didn't have the best relation
with his father that could be also a
trend that you notice but that wasn't a
case with you guys no I was very lucky
so as a person living in San Fran you're
seeing that taking place they're
targeting your kids what what moves are
you making are you playing offense are
you sitting there saying you know this
is number one priority I'm going to find
out everything about this because you're
not in a state that is on your side they
don't they don't protect you you're in a
state that they protect their political
you know policies and whatever they want
to do they're not going to favor a
mother or parent telling their kids who
they should be well that's the fun part
because early on I played defense you
can't win a game playing defense so we
went on the offensive in California and
I wrote a I wrote six bills um and I
shopped them around and one Republican
lawmaker um assemblyman Bill aale picked
it up up and uh we went on the offensive
and it's been really quite you know
amazing to see that California is making
this change so we have um parental
notification policies that are being
passed in in in schools now and that's
all
because we decided to go on the
offensive and that's what we're doing
and we're going to continue to do that
um that's why we're doing the initiative
is we can't play defense and they should
be actually afraid of us because parents
we're powerful if we all join forces we
are powerful and we can stop this even
in the most liberal state in the Union
we can stop this are you noticing you
you uh uh uh unifying with other parents
mothers who are Republicans cuz you're
not one you're a Democrat and you're
sitting there saying well we have
something in common here you know our
kids we're going to fight for our kids
you know is it bringing you know because
offline you and I were talking and you
said you know every parent wants this
for their kids and I said for me I don't
understand why some parents are caving
in and they're like it's almost as if
it's politics before their kids and you
said I don't think that's the case you
said it's something else if you want to
unpack that for the audience because to
some of us we're sitting there saying
well that's you know liberal policies
it's being liberal if your kid wants to
do that let them if they want to do this
let them but you're saying that's not
the case it's not the case and the media
is not presenting it so even getting my
name in the media is almost impossible
because I'm a Democrat they don't want
to put my name out there they don't want
anyone to find me that you know a
liberal Democrat is actually against
this and you know I run a parent group
about 80% of us are Democrats or were
Democrats we all voting Republican in
2024 just so you know but but we were
Democrats and and we're against this but
the media doesn't ever Spotlight this
fact we are hidden we are the best kept
secret so yes the Democrats are standing
with the Republican
look my reach is I've got the radical
feminists all the way on the on the left
are fighting this and then I've got the
evangelicals on the right and we are all
joining hands and so the Democrats
should actually be really scared because
we are going on the offensive and we are
putting our differences aside to
safeguard kids and shocking we actually
have more in common than I ever thought
you know hanging out with um Republican
groups I'm like actually we agree on
about 80% of the same things they siloed
us they wanted us to think each other
are monsters we're not we actually have
so much in common and we have to use
that you know to stop this can I ask you
a question you you mentioned about Gavin
NM and about four weeks ago um and I
read it and I read a lot of um uh in the
in the media that it was Gavin trying to
walk to the center to getting ready for
presidential run but he backed off a
bill a trans and parent notification
Bill were you involved in that were you
lobbying on that can you unpack that
because the narrative people heard that
I read that bill that I read was oh
Gavin's running to the center he wants
to look like he's in the center and he
also you know vetoed other bills about
having you know um self-driving trucks
were okay and it's all about entric but
it sounds like your fingerprints are all
over what he did can you unpack it yeah
you're correct um we were fighting ab9
57 which is a bill that would have
forced uh judges to uh find that the
health safety and Welfare of a child
it's their best interest to support
their transgender identity against the
parents against the parents got it and
the reason I mean let's be clear I'm
really happy that that Nome vetoed that
and it was a huge win because this is
what they were trying to do and most
people missed this they looked at the
bill and said this is just in divorce so
in divorce they're going to favor the
parent who affirms the child but when
you tie those three words health safety
and Welfare to supporting a trans
identity now you just made it child
abuse so parents like me could have had
my child taken because I wouldn't
transition my child so it was bigger
than that it's actually um you know the
opposite of Texas it would have been
penalizing parents who would not
transition their kids what Gavin Newsome
knows and what I know is that when there
is a divorce situation and there's one
parent supporting the transgender
identity and one that's not the parent
who is supporting the trans identity
always gets the kid in California that's
already happening this bill was going to
add to it to make it you know child
abuse so if you're disingenuous that's
your custody hack exactly exactly so he
was you know they were trying to go
through the back door I know Scott
weiner Scott weiner was the author of
this bill I watch this guy I study this
guy um I know what they're doing I I
read everything in California but let me
just talk about one bill that Gavin
Newsome did approve because it's it's
the scariest Bill I've ever seen it's AB
665 what this bill does is it's state
sanction kidnapping 12y olds if you're
12 or older these kids can run away to a
statun uh facility residential facility
with no claim of abuse on their on their
parents for no reason for any reason
they can run away
and they can get housed away from their
wa you call State sanctioned kidnapping
yes because the state is allowing a
12-year-old for any reason to take off
from their family and go live in a
residential facility did this approve
yes so Gavin Nome signed that into law
that is a terribly frightening bill so
in the world of trans it goes something
like this you've got a seventh grader
who goes into their school counselor and
says I'm trans and my parents won't
support
it
okay what would you like to stay in a
residential facility would you like to
stay away from your bigot it hateful
family will send you to this facility
and off the kid goes you said there let
me interrupt you for people listening
you between the lines there you said and
there does not have to be any record of
abuse or something that the child has
reported or maybe got a family member to
help report a parent zero on record they
can walk in and do this zero zero so
this is the blowing up of the family and
this is taking the child when the child
is 12 years old and we know what's H
what happens when they go to these
residential facilities what can parents
do to fight that well there's going to
be a lawsuit against that uh against
that bill so I need people who have kids
that are ages 12 to 17 to reach out to
me um because we need to line up the
plain ofs we need to fight that bill
quickly in the courts before parents
before 12-year-olds can just walk out
the door and parents don't see them
again there's there's a couple things
here folks if you're listening to this
you know every parent I would recommend
if you're dealing with anything you can
ask a direct questions you're on man now
I think you talked to Lisa Lisa you can
find Ain on man Rob if you can put the
link in the chat as well as in the
description for people to see it ask any
questions you have on manck you can get
a hold of as well as there's a website
called protect kids CA
uh.com that you can also go to ollie I
want to come to you uh for complete
different thing here my wife and I we're
in um I don't know where we were at
we're having dinner somewhere we're
skiing whatever one of these mountains
we skiing we go to this nice restaurant
this fellow comes and is serving us very
nice guy extremely attentive I love
great servers who are paying attention I
don't need to tell them you know Arnold
Palmer 8020 IC tea and it comes back
it's 8020 lemonade just small little
details that I like okay refill
constantly refill doesn't let the the
glass stay empty for more than 2 minutes
and then boom comes back and does it
right and I'm like so you know tell me
about yourself yeah I'm this this that
and then all of a sudden he opens up he
says yeah well I'm gay and all these
things Okay cool so I said tell me about
your relationship with your dad oh I
hate him tell me why he did this this
this this that everywhere I go I'm a
pattern guy I'm a numbers guy I'm
curious I ask questions and one of the
common Trends you'll notice especially
with a boy is a relationship with father
that's either not there it's missing or
when the boy was going through certain
phases in his life that he was confused
that person wasn't there fatherless
Holmes what was that experience for you
as a young boy not today as a young boy
when you're going through where at some
points you needed to talk to somebody
but he didn't have anybody yeah I had a
very difficult relationship with my
father he was very emotionally abusive
and manipulative to my mother so I would
always witness him putting her down
making her feel worthless and you know
he would also Al do the same to me um
and you know if I would go against his
word or if I didn't want to do something
he wanted to do you know he would get
very angry at me and put me down so he
was trying to mold me in his vision of
the world you know to be become like him
and I wanted to become like my mother so
that's why I kind of became attached to
women and you know feminine figures as
opposed to the masculine role model so I
didn't have that good masculine role
model and I think that was really a big
part of the problem and for many uh
people that do Transition there is an
normally an issue with the family unit
so there's normally an issue with the
father uh maybe they lack that strong
role model maybe they have you know come
from a broken home or they've suffered
from something so that really really
affected me and you know he walked out
on my family one day and you know never
spoke to him since and never spoke to
him since just walked out how old were
you when he walked out um so I was in my
early 20s when he did that but he was
always just leaving and not coming back
for a long time and you know he was he
was not nice and you know I think that
really played a big part in you know my
confusion because I was like I would
want to be like this person I don't want
to become like this this horrible man
that is abusive to this person that I
love my mother and abusive to me you
know I want to become more like my
mother and more feminine and soft and
you know gentle so that really affected
me and you know the family unit is such
an important thing Ali so let me let me
ask you so somebody may be watching this
as a father and they may say man [__]
sometimes I'm pretty bad to my kids
they'll improve okay Cole and they'll
make it work some some fathers May
listen to this and they're like man I
haven't checked on my kid for a while
let me call back okay let's just say
that on proof but you know some people
who listen to this and they say that's
right my dad wasn't there and he hasn't
been there and he was abusive and the
only person I ever experienced
unconditional love from was my mom and I
want to be feminine and I want to be
this what do you tell the person that
doesn't have an example of you know how
do you what do you tell the boy that's
like this is exactly what I'm going
through and no one understands me no one
knows what I'm going through right now
at that face cuz you think you're the
only person that's going through this
what do you tell them right yeah most of
these people they do feel very isolated
and alone and it's very hard to know who
to talk to because a lot of people these
days they bottle up their feelings or
they maybe take to social media and they
start to see these trends that are
pushed on them and you know then they
get that confusion they get depression
so we see a lot of mental health
struggles right now so you know I would
just tell people be strong you know find
a purpose in life I think that's very
important whether that's a a career uh
that you want to do you want to focus on
a career something studying or going to
church or or something or a sports you
know skill into sports I think having a
focus in life because you know a lot of
people these days feel very lost you
know they graduate from college they
don't know what to do with their lives
they're confused you know they might be
confused with their gender so you know
you have to have something in your life
that keeps you going that gives you
strength and have goals to set yourself
to work towards so you know a career or
for me going to church you know weekly
and going to Bible readings I went to
one yesterday in Palm Beach you know
doing things like that is very
motivating and it can keep you going you
know when times are difficult Al in UK
it's different than obviously in the
States but you've also said things about
what's going on in US you've made
specific comments about uh you know ex
transgender influencer uh oi London
warns us needs to wake up to this child
uh danger it's not right so how
different are things in UK versus what
you're seeing in the states so the US is
a lot more extreme in terms of
transitioning kids and you see uh a huge
number of cases in the US there's around
1.6 million uh people in America that
identify as trans and that has gone up
by 600,000 just in the last few years so
we're seeing this sharp uh kind of
increase um the UK we're seeing a lot of
schools now being INF infiltrated with
gender ideology and woke culture and you
know it's really being pushed and then
obviously social media is pushing that
um so we are starting to see a lot more
of it however the UK's National Health
Service did ban puberty blockers um and
they have made it very very difficult
for teens to get these hormones because
at the end of the day you know people in
the UK woke up and like this is not fair
kids cannot consent to this and you
can't drive a car you can't smoke so you
know people have woken up but there are
woke policies being pushed um you know
for instance the UK's National Health
Service was allowing uh transgender
patients to be in women's only Wards so
you know imagine if you've just uh given
birth or you've been through a sexual
assault and you're in hospital and then
you you have a biological men next to it
that can be very upsetting for people so
you know the the government has
announced they are kind of stopping that
and trying to protect women's spaces and
you know there's a real kind of cultural
battle there but whereas the US is a lot
more extreme obviously you have uh
Republican states you know 19 have got
legislation Banning gender affirming
care whereas you look in you know places
like New York or California and there
are so many kids being encouraged and
incentivized to transition I mean you
know as Erin was saying in in schools
you know that is really kind of the
grand zero where this is happening
because you have groups of particularly
girls in the same class they are
suddenly changing their pronouns they're
becoming trans the teacher is then
affirming that and not even telling the
parents and you know like in your case
you you weren't aware of what was going
on because the the teachers don't say so
it's a lot more extreme here but I think
a lot of people are waking up and I
think that's you know great what Luca is
doing and Erin and you know for you as
well hosting this podcast today is
speaking up because we can't be silent
you know parents need to speak up
because it's it's now or never you know
we're losing so many kids to this
transgender crisis and we're going to
see in a couple of years you know
thousands and thousands of more kids
detransitioning regret rate and you know
they're going to be of is stuck of what
to do I'm going to ask a question Tom
and I want you to go to yours so here's
my question for you you know when I
lived in Iran uh uh it was always you
know fashion comes from Italy to Iran
whatever they wear in Europe then we
wear right and then you live here and
you're thinking well us has got to be
more fashionable right no it's really
what Europe wears and then we wear right
okay and you've said whatever California
does everybody else will do in America
right so if California gets to this
place odds are it's going to come to
your State here very soon right do you
do you from UK do you see folks in UK
who look at the states and California
says oh they're doing that we should too
because they're the cool people or do
you guys look at us and you like these
guys have lost their mind what the hell
are they doing they're out of there we
lead them not the other way around how
do you view us you know what I'm asking
yeah I mean most of Europe we always do
follow us Trends you know in terms of
Hollywood in terms of what's cool on
social media so we do often but I think
there's a lot of people that are more
awake a lot of parents and British
people they're quite outspoken you know
they're they're not afraid to say look
this is wrong and you know the parent
will go to that school and say stop
teaching our kids this and you know they
will speak out against it petition their
Member of Parliament so I think people
are more proactive in speaking out
whereas in America you have this very
strong cancel culture so you know anyone
that speaks out can be fired we've seen
you know Christian teachers that have
been fired and and others that lose
their jobs for misgendering a child or
not affirming that child's gender
identity so you know whereas in the UK
we don't have such an extreme as in
people are losing their jobs um but we
are seeing more and more young people
teenagers identifying as transs and you
know it's not just a trend where they're
coloring their hair they're actually
physically wanting to cut off body parts
and transition and you know it's it's
we've always had Trends people you know
in the 80s and 70s there have been
examples throughout history of people
that have identified as the opposite um
gender but what we're seeing now is a
social contagion which is being led by
social media and you know social media
is mostly Amer it's Instagram it's
Facebook obviously you have China which
has Tik Tok which has played one of the
most significant roles in this but yeah
I think in terms of social media trends
they do come from the US and seep into
Europe and you know young people are
being affected by
that very articulate really appreciate
your points you you talked about your
relationship with your parents and then
you're going into adolescence were you
getting where was the social
encouragement or social ratification
because I see what you mean hey you go
to a psychologist and all of a sudden
all that they are is ratify ratify
ratify ratify your your bad parents are
there so they're actually lobbying not
processing did you have at at the time
was there what were the social
influences from school or whatever that
were ratifying that helped that helped
you make that decision well I was always
bullied uh at high school and told that
I was like a girl you know when I would
go swimming I used to have man boobs so
I would get really teased about that and
that really really affected me and then
you know it made me have the mentality
as you know was I born in the wrong body
am I meant to be a girl and then in
adolescence I kind of just started doing
surgery because I'd always had low
self-esteem because of this and that
kind of became worse and worse and then
you know I started being a very heavy
user on social media so you know when
Facebook came about Instagram Myspace
back in the day that was kind of more
innocent back that was the best I know
um so yeah and then within the last 5
years you know I became very addicted to
social media and obviously you know Tik
Tok came around 2018 and that was when I
really started to push myself and think
you know what let me do this let me do
this transition let me change my gender
and then you know all I start to see is
videos online and you see somebody that
transitions they suddenly get praise
they get love they get validation and I
was lacking that and that was a big part
of it that's very interesting uh we had
a gentleman on a couple weeks ago Bob
Woodson it does a lot with at risk youth
and one of the things that um uh
churches in the inner city that were
desperately trying to heal the gang
situation pointed out that young men
need love discipline and respect in big
doses starting at age 12 and when they
don't get it the gangs provide that to
them in almost the most opposite but
perverse form but I'm accepted I'm loved
and they have discipline and it's
interesting we talk about youth needing
some needing a magnetism needing to
magnet to like a parent or a support and
I think you all are talking about
this in terms of what the kids need and
but what they get how do you how do you
identify what would have helped you
early
on to to kind of counteract that because
a kid a drift is just going to connect
whether it's a gangs or ratification on
social media what do the cues parents
look for and how can they be involved
because you've all have had Direct
experience yeah I mean I think there
variety of things you know school can be
an influence obviously I grew up in a
different time so we didn't have the
trans Trend in the schools but again uh
as I was growing up you know I started
using social media back in the early
days and it was for me it was that
validation so a lot of kids uh simply
they might be struggling with depression
with the way they look or even sexuality
we see now a lot of people that would
normally just be gay or lesbian they are
now becoming trans because they're being
told that's the trend so you know for me
it was that kind of um confusion and
people around me always telling me to be
a girl so when you have a kid that's
maybe lonely they've been bullied and
you know they don't have kind of
positive role models in their life you
start to become a drift and then you
start to want to kind of transform
yourself completely look I got a
question for you yeah you're Minnesota
right okay so 21 years old born in 2002
okay but when you were at the age that
you were Tik Tok was musically it's what
you said earlier yeah um when the event
took place and you're kind of going
through the process where these
surgeries are going to happen and you're
coming home how are your parents talking
to you are your parents sitting there
saying babe you sure you want to do this
babe are you sure you want to do this
babe you can think about it why don't
you wait till you're 18 you know you
don't have to hurry up we can wait to do
this what was your parents approach with
the decision you could make so at the
time my so my parents were divorced and
this is it was not a pretty divorce
which was almost kind of some of the
Catalyst of this because you look like
when I was like 12 13 14 there was a lot
going on so of course I like
retreated away from myself um when did
they go to what how old were you when
the divorce happened so I believe I
would have been 12 so the divorce when
the divorce happens that means divorce
been happening for a few years when when
did you kind of see like this is going
to eventually happen let's just see how
long they're going to take um you know
what I'm asking I I really didn't
because they they tried they tried their
best but it was actually right before
they like officially got divorced that's
when I also got a
smartphone um because of the fact that
they're like okay well you're going to
be switching back and forth between
houses now um you're going to like this
is might be helpful and that's kind of
the only reason I got one when I was
like 12 almost 13 um but so two very
different perspectives from my parents
um my my mom did come with me with come
to me with some concerns um and she was
like I I'm scared to regret this she
expressed this to the therapist I was
seeing at the time and that was shut
down and she had private sessions with
this therapists and they essentially
talked her out of expressing those
concerns like that that to me um
meanwhile you had the whole trans
Community kind of feeding it in your ear
that if your parents don't immediately
go along with all this if they don't
affirm you essentially they're hateful
they're hateful people and here's I had
I had no reason you know for to believe
that they were and I I I feel like even
as like a 16-year-old I tried my best to
understand what they were going through
now I I will say it was from my my lens
of like my 16-year-old brain so probably
not the most um you know informed there
but um
I my mom had concerns if my dad had any
concerns he never brought them forward
to me
um
he but he my my dad is very very like
analytical if that's the right word
where he was very like okay well here's
the medical professionals are telling me
this is the problem and that's the
solution so we're going with it um in
that sense he there was also the fact
that he he liked having a special child
that he could affirm for like the virtue
points um he did which is which is
something I don't talk a ton about
because I I try to my able to keep my
family out of stuff but he my my dad is
a man who very
much uh was
very Progressive in the sense of like
like hardcore like Boomer
progressivism if anyone knows what I'm
talking about there um unpack that what
does that mean it is just um
essentially like I am being told this is
the nice and right thing to do so I'm
going to believe it
wholeheartedly um cuz I grew up being
told that this is the good thing and
this is what the good people do and so
I'm not going to question it my my dad
watched CNN and MSM all he was just so
mad all the time throughout my high
school years about stuff and then he he
did enjoy He he'll never admit to it
because he's kind of a textbook case of
a narcissist and if he's watching this
because he knows I'm on it hi um don't
talk to me but oh wow um but no so he he
was he was a he was a case of really
feeding into that affirmation cycle
because of the fact that like he once
again whether to admit to it or not he
enjoyed having you know the the special
kid that gives you political points when
you affirm them and you are very
virtuous with how you how you present
all this look at me I'm such a good
person I have such a marginalized child
and I am I am affirming them all the way
through and I'm sticking by this cuz
this is now my struggle too um and that
actually got to a point where when I was
about 17 wouldn't right before I stopped
switching houses
um I called my mom at one point and I
was curled up on the bathroom floor of
of um my bathroom at his house and I was
on the phone with my mom and I was
absolutely
sobbing um and I I asked her why doesn't
he love me me for anything else besides
being
trans and that is where you see these
parents and it it it it hits a special
chord with me when you see these
activist parents that have especially
the young children that are affirming
this because when these kids grow up and
they get to that place where I was
curled up on that bathroom floor um
talking to my mom when they get to a
place like that and they realize that
they their parents have essentially put
all the eggs in the basket of you know
this is what makes you amazing this is
what makes you special this is great I'm
affirming you that's going to break
those kids it's going to break them
especially if they especially if this
started at like six seven 8 nine any of
those younger ages cuz I was a teenager
but imagine going your whole
life with your parent telling you this
and then coming to the realization that
like they didn't seem to care about you
for anything else besides that Luka let
me let me let me ask
you parents politically are they both
Democrats
um yes Minnesota I I well so my parents
are originally from Nebraska I live in
Minnesota now um which is you want to
talk about California Minnesota is just
the California of the Midwest um but
both my parents were I believe my dad's
Democrat I think my mom is registered as
an independent but has voted Democrat
got it so this is why uh Erin I know you
you don't necessarily think you know
agree with what I was saying on this
side I think there are certain people
that choose their politics and whatever
their political party affiliation the
loyalty to their political party and
philosophy is above uh any of it every
parent is proud to brag about their kids
not every parent I would say most
parents want to brag and say that's my
kid because it's like a way you're
bragging about yourself it's your
genetics it's my blood it's it's a it's
a different way you brag about your kids
but when you brag about it to show off
to your party to say I'm more liberal
than you are look at me look how loyal I
am to my political party and I get these
additional points that you don't get uh
being the fifth person that uh uh chose
to sue uh uh the institution that help
you know got you to transition are are
you all finding each other and are you
communicating others that are in a
situation like you that went through
what you went through and if you were to
put 50 stories on the board are all 50
have the same six components five
components three Trends or are there
different reason why kids go through
transitioning um I just I guess add a
mini asteris to the the parent thing is
it is it tends to be a certain
personality type that that this kind of
ideology appeals to feeding into their
ego so it's not necessarily even
politics it is like a if you have a
narcissistic tendency you're going to do
anything to feed your ego and
unfortunately this topic feeds their ego
um but to I've I've yeah I've met a lot
of the other D transitioners I've met
most of the other ones that are are
filing lawsuits and it's it's really is
amazing because I know I know like the
concept of diversity gets harped on a
lot now because of how it's implemented
but the transitioners are truly one of
the most like diverse groups of people I
have ever been
around um you know we're from different
backgrounds different races different
religions different political beliefs
but all through all of our stories there
is a thread of these certain things that
happen
and it's just woven in there and that's
kind of what is pulling us all together
um there's a thread of you know events
such as you know family life problems
sexual trauma um internalized or
external homophobia um all of all of
these things just general being
uncomfortable in puberty social media
and being like influenced by this stuff
to feel accepted but all throughout all
of it there is
a there's a young person in each of
these stories that just wanted
acceptance and just wanted to feel loved
and wanted and unfortunately for a lot
of us that came from a very predatory
place in our lives when you hear that
what do you think about
ER that is really truthful so I I run a
parent group and all I need is the
parent to give me the age and the sex of
the child and I can guess the story and
the story I'm I'm usually spot on you
know so when a parent comes in and they
have a uh a female teenager I can say
not in the cool crowd into anime watch
too much porn uh you know hides in the
room with social media like they they
patterns and they're so obvious to us if
it's a boy I've got a different pattern
these boys are highly intelligent
usually Asbergers on the Spectrum
somewhere
um they're usually uncomfortable around
girls never had a girlfriend so there's
these
really stunning patterns that we see day
in and day out that the doctors seem to
just ignore so we see
them and it and it pray and you know
Luca is right it prays on the vulnerable
kids these are not the kids that are
great at sports or in the popular group
these are the kids that are Fringe and
outliers and are looking for a tribe or
are looking for love from both their
friends and sometimes from their parents
and then they can opt into this stardom
I mean when you are a quote unquote
trans kid you are celebrated you become
the IT person even though the kids still
shy away from you so you'll see a a boy
who will become prom queen or homecoming
queen he's not invited to the after
party but you know all the kids are
celebrating this this boy in a dress but
it's all a false
celebration you know it's interesting
you say that because we're starting to
see people waking up to this bill Mah
woke up and Bill said that he was
alarmed and he did a little monologue on
it that he said around he said angelinos
which is people from Los Angeles he says
I'm starting to see angelinos at
cocktail parties speaking with Pride
about having a kid that's transitioning
and they're like oh what what drama as
if you know they you they're they're
just talking casually about some topic
you know you and him being very alarmed
by that you just talked
about about patterns you can see in kids
what patterns do you see in
parents well like Lucas said
narcissistic parents parents who want to
I mean there is a political component of
it you know Democrats liberals how
liberal can you be you're so liberal
that you're accepting that your child is
actually the opposite sex I mean that's
a you know it's a badge of honor right
um and and these parents can show how
how woke they are and accepting they are
on this so yeah there's a lot of
narcissism I mean you see the you see
the parents who are parading their quote
unquote trans kids around I mean that's
a you know especially the little kids
now those parents are as
narcissistic as they come they're sick
though the these are sick people they
have issues they're they're you can say
narcissistic all you want and we can
call them all these other categories
let's just simplify you are sick you
have issues if you are using your kid to
advertise you know uh uh as a prop hey
look who I am as a parent you have
mental issues you're the one with mental
issues not your kids you're using your
kids to fill your own Gap
um I I don't have any forgiveness for
them I I for the for the parents who are
prating the young kids around I I don't
have any forgiveness they are foisting
this on these children and they are
using these children as props I mean you
can listen to every parent who says that
they have a a trans young kid and and
the stories are all the same my son
played with
Barbies big deal I played with
trucks um I I would just add to that
also is one of those things when you
think about um the these adults who are
very affirming and and you give it like
more than more than two seconds of
thought why would you want to be the
adult that when a young person comes to
you and they are they are distressed and
they are they are saying every single
thing is wrong with me down to my very
being down to my very
body why would you be the adult in the
room to look that kid in the eyes and
say yes you are right everything is
wrong with you and we're going to we're
we'll take you and get all this stuff
done to you to fix you why would you be
that adult how is that loving or caring
to look that young person in the eyes
who is so distressed that they want to
escape their very physical body and tell
them that yes you are correct everything
is wrong with you well you just said it
it's like that that parent has got deep
insecurities and issues of their own and
we're talking about the kids and their
emotional things and all this but the
parents have got their own basket of but
you know what I think about that Tom
here's here's what I think about you
know again off camera we spoke for 2
minutes and I feel like we had a podcast
off camera to me I said common sense you
know you have common sense you know this
shit's not uh you know normal for you to
do what you're doing with your kid but
but here's here's where I go to as well
um so think let's be deceptive for a
second and let's play Devil's Advocate
and let's play the the motives of some
people who are dark let's just say those
people exist okay how do you do it it's
not a new strategy suu talked about it
many years ago divide and conquer okay
so how do we do it divide parents great
divorce rate in US is the highest in the
world awesome let's divide parents we're
killing it that's not the case in China
it's 3% it's not the case in India it's
4% we're at freaking you know whatever
what's the divorce rate in us if you
pull it up it's absolutely embarrassing
so let's divide parents one Bingo we're
winning number two let's divide Sexes
we're doing that let's divide them let's
pin men against women freaking awesome
look at these guys they hate each other
the feminist movement greatest thing
ever women coming out seeing the Enemy
of the State number one is men this is
who are let's let's let's wage a class
war you know let's let's make the poor
hate the rich and the rich hate the poor
let's do that and then what happens
protesting destroying businesses the
people that create jobs they're
destroying small go look at this we're
winning this is so awesome and then you
got to also kind of you know get values
out the the fewer the few like I'm
watching this interview with this guy
Rob do you have this interview with this
um this child molester who is being
interviewed and he's given us Clues on
what he does he says I look at kids who
are not close with their parents who
don't have a strong Father Figure uh uh
uh I'll send you the video here in a
minute so we don't have to play it's not
a big deal but one of the things he
talks about this is a guy that did 12
Years two or three years in jail and he
went in for being a child molester and
he's being interviewed he agrees to do
an interview on what his strategy is
okay and he said he looked for Clues
strong father he wouldn't even waste his
time okay believed in God wouldn't this
guy right here how many minutes is it 2
minutes and 11 seconds what channel is
this with that we can play it or not can
you see what this is it's just a regular
thing this is such a long time ago okay
go ahead and play it see what this guy
says if you can put the audio Rob I
found my victims moving from town to
town um convict the child him out on um
school grounds I scoped him out in
Little League diamonds um I scoped them
out in my own backyards my neighborhoods
and things like that um I worked with
people who had younger brothers I
socialized with those people so I could
get in touch with their younger
brothers and begin The Grooming
process and
um
eventually it would take time but I knew
what I was doing it was all
calculated I mean this is nothing that
happened overnight you know I knew and I
planned it all it started out where I
would move from one town to another when
I got located in one town um I
would you know survey the children in
the town to see it was always a small
town it was never a big one um because
big towns have big police force
and big police forces tend not to be
very friendly small towns have small
police forces you know they probably
never even heard of a child molester or
a sex offender or never even had to deal
with one I knew that at least I played
upon
that and um I got involved in Little
League Baseball because I knew from my
high school days that I could umpire
Little League Baseball I could umpire
base
I was good at it I was good at
refereeing basketball and other sports
because I could not play worth the crap
in high school but I enjoyed the sport
so much you can pause this Ro this not
the clip this this is a longer interview
one of the clips he talks about what he
look for but this this the thing that I
think about if a father or a
mother caves to this nonsense you don't
really have core values and principles
that you stand by because a person that
has real true values and principles you
can't break them you just person is
going to be like no I'm good I'm not
going to do it yeah I'm I'm not I'm not
okay with this so the same way they
divided between men and women the same
way they divided between husband and
wife the same they divided between the
job creators and the people that the the
class war that we're talking about
financially it's the same way they're
saying hey guys we don't need Church in
schools we don't need prayer in school
we don't need to believe in a God we
don't need to so I need to believe in
lgbtq is what you're saying but I don't
need to believe in God got it so your
God was
replaced by this lgbtq nonsense and then
gradually you go in there and if you are
able to get me to not believe in God
what do I no longer have I no longer
have faith a community of people that no
longer have faith whether the Bible is
true or not whether Jesus is real or not
whether your faith is real or not I
don't have faith anymore the moment I
don't have faith anymore you have a a
crack in the argument I can get in there
and and play my manipulative game but if
a group of people have faith how do I go
up against the community like that that
so I see I see a lot of this trend as
well happening because think about it
this way you're a liberal 30 said 36 37
years I don't know what the timeline was
30 plus years uh Democrat you said
you're not voting Democrat in 2024
that's what you said you said you're
voting Republican 20124 but how come how
come you don't
notice Republican parents being okay
with transitioning doesn't happen that
often it's few of them how come it's
mainly democratic parents that are doing
I'll come to you in a second how come
it's mainly Democratic parents that are
doing this what is typically the if you
were to say which one has a side that
believes in God more or less generally
it's going to be more Republicans that
believe in God than Democrats okay so if
you're a republican you probably go to
an institution where somebody's
preaching every week and they're given a
certain set of values and principles
then you eventually are like well that's
kind of my value and Principle as well
then you're not going to let somebody
bully you and you're not going to break
and like there's no way we're going to
be doing something like this to our kids
I'm going to stand firm on this but
Democrats you're probably not going to a
church on Sunday you probably don't have
a certain you know religion not all I'm
not telling all I'm purely talking uh
percentages this data is out there as
well so it's an easier Target to go
after so if an institution wants to go
after a community to transition their
kids Democrats are the best targets
Republicans are the worse go ahead I
think you were going to say something um
I was I was just going to say well you
you talk about religion and when you
look at how essentially this entire
social movement whether it be the trans
things or the surrounding little bubbles
that are kind of tied to it um it it
fits what these people see as
essentially a non-theistic religion so
original where there is there is no
there is no God but it fits having
you've heard the the phrases trans kid
are trans kids are sacred trans people
are holy you are going through
essentially all of the steps of a
religion except you are do not have a
God that you're praying to in the end of
this they are worshiping every day on
social media cuz they've made this their
religion this is dark and you can see in
the fervor that they talk about things
that they believe it it is and you have
people like James Lindsay who talk a lot
about this he was just at a conference
we were at this past weekend um but
essentially the entirety of modern day
progressivism especially in like my age
like college I'm 21 so like college kids
age um this this not only do they not
have a religion they've replaced it with
this being their religion and when you
think about it like that that is a lot
more Sinister cuz that is a lot more um
that you have to break down to even have
that conversation and that is why you
see where they don't have that
conversation no debate is a phrase that
is used on this topic a lot there is no
debate because they believe in their
heart of hearts that they know 100% what
they're doing is right and that is a
quote from a direct Doctor Who put a
clip out on Twitter saying that they
believe it it is not they don't care
that the science is awful and weak and
very low evidence that doesn't matter on
this topic because they believe in it by
the way you're in college right now I I
am not um I so I had to take a break
last spring from because of health
issues um caused by my transition I had
to pull out because I my my joint pain
and pelvic pain so bad I couldn't get
out of bed um but honestly um best
decision I've ever made I I went to a
school where the the medical students
during their white coat ceremony called
biological sex an oppressive construct
that needs to be dismantled I had a
professor tell me that Charles Darwin's
theory of evolution is directly
responsible for generational trauma I
don't think you guys realize just how
bad it is however bad you think it is
it's
worse we by the way it's crazy you're
think I'm sure you're thinking our
conversation this last week with you
know what I'm talking about yes I do go
ahead please well and also I mean if you
think about transgenderism there's a
gendered Soul this is what they say that
there's a gender Essence so they're
actually transgenderism is a new
religion it's based on faith in
intangible and you are a True Believer
we hear that terminology too you are a
True Believer and D transitioners are
just the apostates and boy oh boy do we
get treated like them to the to the
point where in some like reading lists
that have been put out for what would
help D transitioners you have cult
deprogram books in them like that is
something that has been recommended to
me over and over again like have you
ever read books by people who have
escaped a cult that might help you um d
d transitioners are treated the way that
like apostates to a hostile religion
would be treated wait wait unpack that
for me so you're saying like so for
example you have transitioned now you
want to leave they fear you leaving
because it's going to show a you know a
leak in their argument and they have to
prevent you from leaving that's why
they're recommending these books they
they it is essentially the word d
transition is a very very scary one to
the trans Community to the point that
the first therapy appointment I went to
after after I detransitioned because I
was like okay I'm going through it I
should probably like you know go find
someone to talk to um in that first
therapy appointment she um the therapist
was like well have you tried just
identifying as non-binary or essentially
anything else that wouldn't make me a d
transitioner because that is a very
scary term to them and they downplay it
a lot with oh it's only a small
percentage we don't know the actual
percent because they don't keep track of
it D transitioners don't go back to the
scene of the crime or to the doctor
where this happened um why would you why
would you go back to the place that the
darkest moments in your life were
affirmed into reality point and I hear a
lot of negative words in the research
coming up this and I didn't even realize
how Negative they were but you just
saying that clicked with me I was seeing
things like I'm stuck in a woman's body
I'm trapped those are highly negative
words like I'm imprisoned like you need
to be liberated you need to find this
other Faith the um the concept the
psychology of that is really dark the
concept in transgenderism and this is
this also applies to broader other
similar social movements um of that you
are not your body you are simply in it
like like Aaron mentioned like a
gendered soul that you are living in
your body you are not your body you are
physically not connected to this thing
that your brain and your body can be
completely separated and have no effect
on each other at all this is just my
vessel I'm here your vessel is a good
way to put it is essentially one of the
most dangerous things we are teaching
young people because they are they are
hearing this that you are just you know
hear you hear outside of you know
outside of transgend well you hear I'm
living in a female body I'm living in a
you know black body or fat body any of
these other movements um and the
separation of the self from your
physical being has to be one of the most
harmful things we are telling young
people that I do not see disgust nearly
enough because part of you know
accepting and part of my D transitioning
was realizing I am my body and you know
that's okay and sometimes that's going
to suck but you know what it's worth it
because that's having two feet in
reality and remending that break that is
being taught to young people of mind and
body remending that so they can actually
feel whole
is what we need to be doing but instead
we currently live in a culture that is
further further separating the two this
is powerful this is powerful too as you
brought up I got the chills all of my
body by the way I I have I have complete
chills the the the pedophile aspect of
this too let let let's put this body
dissociation is what Luca is talking
about I'm I'm sure Ali you you
experienced body dis dissociation it is
what is being taught actually to our
kids so you are not your body so think
about this and this this happened in in
my personal situation is that my
daughter was being coached online as
soon as she put on Instagram female to
male this is a calling card for
pedophiles pedophiles look at this girl
and they say she is vulnerable she is
disassociating with her body she's
claiming that her body is not actually
hers she's my target 100% yeah they go
after them and they and they ask these
young girls to um sell naked pictures of
themselves uh because after all they're
going to get those breasts removed
anyway so why not use them for some cash
this is a real thing that is happening
they also look at these young girls and
say let's get her on testosterone
because you know what testosterone does
to a female it turns all the nose into
yeses it turns us
into you know or women into being much
more promiscuous than one would be
because we don't have that that hormone
in the same way that men do I mean we
have testosterone in our bodies but not
to the effect that you do and so you
pump a young girl with testosterone and
you're going to have a very promiscuous
young girl so this is all designed this
is all related to pedopilia also um and
they take advantage of that this is not
your this is not your body and this is
where also belief is more important
trans women are women that's based on
what they believe and also there's a
desensitization I mean if you look at a
pride event you know you see a
sexualization you see people in fetish
gear bondage BDSM on the streets and
there will be kids there there are so
many examples this summer during pride
and it's desensitizing people to think
that's perfectly normal and perfectly
acceptable and we should not be allowing
that in society and it has all the signs
of a cult I mean you know in Cults they
sexualize and Target young children
that's one thing uh the people in The
Cult recruit members so they take to Tik
Tok they take to Instagram to recruit
new people to join the trans cult and
then if you leave that cult you are
suppressive person just like with
Scientology for instance you become
supressive person and they will Target
you so if you suddenly announce you've
detransitioned online you are a target
of hatred if you're a woman that says
sorry I don't feel comfortable with you
in my uh restroom you are also targeted
so it's about that kind of suppressive
person targeting and the sexualization
has become normalized this is so
interesting because in faiths if you
think about if you think about faiths
around the world and people call them
religions Faith but in the
judeo-christian tradition so that
includes Mormons Catholics Protestants
it's a very large bucket they're very
clear that the soul and body are
together and the scripture says you are
fearfully and wonderfully made and as
the unit and when you pass away your
spirit is where you know we all go to
heaven and in that that that belief
structure and what they're doing is
they're breaking that up prematurely
into that your your how you're made how
you're born could have had some flaw and
that is just to me I'm just sitting here
thinking about this that is so striking
in the destructiveness of self no wonder
suicide follows in these percentages
because you're now you're now somehow
conning them into believe that how you
were born was somehow a mistake rather
than there's a goodness in you that
needs to be found and the new judeo
Christian tradition the most important
three days the day you're born the day
you decide to follow God and the day you
find out why you're here and what you're
going to do as you do so you see the
power in that and the goodness of where
you're going to find in yourself versus
them breaking all this this is I'm
having an epiphany here listening to you
and it is not a good one um I was also
going to say the separation of like
one's mental state from their body just
like Aaron mentioned is essentially a
predator's dream to have someone so so
disassociated and so desensitized that
they don't care what happens to their
physical body cuz they see their
physical body that can be interchanged
like Legos um and I say this as one of
one of the catalysts that led me to
disassociate so heavily that I was like
I thought I thought I was meant to be a
boy was the fact that I was prayed on
prayed upon online in several of these
in trans spaces where these adults see
that you have young people who hate
their body and are heavily
disassociating from it and they will
pray upon it they use very similar lines
of don't let your parents find out then
you'll be in trouble your parents are
the bad people here they are they don't
understand you I do and they will tell
you that over and over again let me ask
this question you're a lawyer okay and
when some like this happens to your kid
you're going to spend how many hours
have you spent studying the whole mod of
everything that's going on with us how
many hours have you put into this whole
thing since that happened with your
daughter two years okay so give me give
me total hours what's hours what what
would you say actual hours couple
thousand hours easy easy okay so here's
here's my question my question is motive
right yesterday we're at the debate and
we're watching all these guys and we're
watching everything that's going on and
we're kind of studying what's going on
with the marketplace right now and what
is the motive of this person saying this
what is the motive of that person doing
this what is the motive of this okay the
motive here is that guy wants to make
money off of me okay go I get it great
what's the motive of this guy this
person wants to get close to you because
they're trying to get close to uh person
that works with you and you want them to
introduce you to her because they really
like her all right so you want going to
endorse you that you can okay I get your
motive I want motive what is the motive
of transs what is the motive of going to
the kids is it is it purely business
because we just read the numbers how big
it is right the the the uh uh hormone
hor replacement 10.2 billion in 2019
it's going to be higher than that today
you got the male to female gender
reassignment surgery is $190 million in
20 2019 and just getting warmed up and
getting warmed up we can say finances
but it's got to be more than that what
do you think it is so it's this is why
it's so difficult to destroy because
it's a multi-headed Hydra so you have
the money there's huge amounts of money
I mean we have uh David sack um his
craft Ventures just uh invested in Plume
the online seller of uh hormones that
targets kids even though it's supposed
to be 18 above it targets kids because I
lurk in that space there's a huge amount
of money in esgs so everyone all these
companies think that they're getting
good guy points for esgs well fixing
their environmental U footprint is
really expensive social is very
inexpensive governance is is relatively
inexpensive so they're picking the
social so they'll they'll throw a pride
parade I mean that's how they can get
their good guy points um so you have
money I mean there are you're right
there are there's billions of dollars
riding
on vulnerable kids and vulnerable adults
because this is adults too we can't
actually stop at 18 18 to 25 this stuff
should be banned most of these kids are
autistic most of them have mental health
issues um going back years that are not
being resolved so we have money so we
that's an easy one to figure out we also
have Government funding this in the
state of California we have to the tune
of multitude of millions of dollars
pouring into this industry whether
they're building new foster care
facilities for these kids that they're
stealing from parents um whether it's
anti-hate and they siphoning this off to
NOS or nonprofits so the money is a huge
part of it then we just talked about the
sex because sex and money go together
just like you know peas and carrots um
there's always a sex component of it
like I said when you take these
vulnerable girls and
boys I mean you pump a boy with sex as
what sexual desires or sex what do you
mean by sex okay in two ways so the boys
they're pumping these boys with puberty
blockers their bodies never grow into a
man body they have
microsized um
penises um and and they never grow and
this is a fetish movement so the top
porn right now is transgender porn so
these men could be 30 years old but they
look like little boys and you you have
um like links back to like that aspect
of it on even like the top sites you
have W paath which is World professional
association for transgender health I
believe is the what the Acron stands for
um on their latest guidelines they
advocated that unic is a valid gender
identity even for children and if you
followed the links back that they first
posted it went directly to a fetish site
of grown men talking about how they
wanted to castrate young boys wait what
unic unic unic for real for real for
boys so a castrated male essentially is
what a unic is um yeah it goes back to
history for the Egyptians wanted strong
men to protect the queen but they would
castrate them so that they couldn't hook
up with the you you have you have the
top World professional association for
transgender health so w paath that in
their latest guidelines were advocating
for unic as a valid gender identity and
you linked back and it linked you
checked the link on it that I doubt it's
still up now because I'm sure they tried
I'm sure they tried to wipe it did they
keep it up no it's it's it's still there
so we have sex
money we have um coling The Herd we have
Eugenics because we had a dtrans
awareness uh you know event 10 out of
the 11 D transitioners were there were
autistic if they went through with their
transition they would all be sterilized
so let's call The Herd remember plant
Parenthood is the biggest seller of of
cross- seex hormones and plant
Parenthood had its Genesis
in
Eugenics sterilizing the deplorables The
Unwanted um the poor the mentally unwell
so you have that aspect of it and then
we have queer Theory which is the
destruction of everything that's normal
the destruction of the
family when my child was going through
this she was told to call me by my first
name so that she I was no longer mother
so she could separate this is a uh this
is designed to blow away everything that
is good in the world we see queer Theory
going on right now when you see all
these uh protests in in support of Hamas
um this is queer Theory again it has to
keep queering it they have to keep um
finding something that's good and
destroy it destroy the family destroy
the child destroy education keep
destroying it's designed to keep
snowballing until there's nothing left
of our society first amendment being
destroyed but why though actually go why
because okay these same people that want
to do this they also want to make money
okay if you destroy Society you're no
longer going to make money you're going
to make you're going to lose a lot of
your money why would you do that like
you can't have a society of people that
are not working that are you know that
that can't be a net positive to society
why would they do that well that's where
the the aspect of belief comes in at
least in my opinion is one in the in the
transgender aspect you are making a
permanent patient out of someone so even
if like oh well you can't have kids now
okay then we'll just push you down the
line to IVF or sergy or anything else
that will provide money um it is making
a permanent patient because
medicalization in this sense breeds
medicalization you know you have
complications from surgery better have
another surgery you're still
uncomfortable with something better have
another procedure you have you know you
have side effects from taking hormones
well we got to get you on more
medication to fix that um you know it's
it's all of this stuff and it is it is
essentially when when we talk about
essentially you know ruining or queering
the normal it is taking a perfectly
healthy body and destroying it and and
the money the money is coming from
People of Our Generation those of us who
who worked you know 10 12 hours a day
and worked their tails off we're paying
for all of this eventually that money
will dry up so it will end uh but
they're taking our tax dollars and using
our tax dollars to harm harm kids um and
to pay for these medical interventions
using that term loosely in in California
and in Most states medical pays for this
so those are our tax dollars being used
when you're paying for your private
insurance your private insurance is
paying for this you're we're paying into
this Oli I don't I mean you had so many
surgeries were they paid by your no I
paid myself yeah to pay yourself so NIH
didn't do that uh no no no no not for um
because I was changing my nose like I
had six nose jobs I was doing jaw
feminization they weren't doing that now
NIH Tom he's in London a National Health
Service yeah NHS yeah he's sorry
yeah so the motive is based on what
you're saying is money ESG social sex
boys are being pumped to puberty
blockers because their body now grows to
human bodies microp penises top porn
sites is transgender porn we're going to
give a second Point under sex what was
the second one well then the other thing
is then there's another as as Luca was
was bringing up too is there's money
made on the front end and there's money
made on it oh God like a pipeline of a
funnel of other products that can sell
you it is a Non-Stop so also I'm going
to get a little deep here but with the
parents so you you you you break up the
parents and the child so the child runs
away goes into foster care or or goes a
glitter family yes but the parent has to
take all these parenting courses so the
parent is always spending money in the
court systems and hiring people and
hiring attorneys to try to get their
child back they never get their child
back there's so much money in this it's
kind of hidden money um the prisons are
paying for all these gender uh
Transformations for men so that they can
get into women's uh women's prisons
again like plume um the hormone company
is is uh working with stor so they take
they sterilize you and then they buy you
a baby when you want one so there's so
much money to be made on on people's
misery over and over and over again I
mean the detransitioners like Luca said
the doctors don't even know what to do
to help her they they don't I so I went
when I first detransitioned I I went to
a doctor that was at the gender clinic
at my current university cuz I was like
you know I got off testosterone I was
like I need blood work done I need to
see where my levels are at I knew
exactly you know like what I needed for
that um just to see what what what
damage was done essentially is what I
needed to see and um I went there and I
I was very candid I just I just
explained everything to this doctor I'm
like this is what is going on and um she
she looked at me and she said you know
um I want I want to help you but I have
no idea what to do with you there's no
protocol for this and I I am actually
also one of the D transitioners who went
back to the original Octor which is not
very many of us and what did the
say this is just the next step on your
gender
Journey wow um is what I is what I got
told and no no real help was offered um
and here's the thing like at the time I
went back to that clinic I was still
pretty newly detransitioned and I I
would have been willing to like okay you
know what maybe maybe this doctor's
different maybe she will help me maybe
she would understand and instead she
looked mildly panicked through like the
Zoom call cuz this wasn't even in person
um she looked mildly panicked that I
even brought up that I didn't think I
could consent to this stuff um at at 16
with all my mental health issues going
on and told me that this is the next
step of my gender journey and then I had
to pay for the zoom call appointment
which was a
lot and I'm sorry I was going to make a
point regarding that so also these
hospitals they don't want to treat d
transitioners because it makes their
statistics and data look bad so you see
all of these clinics trans activists
they'll claim there's a 1% D transition
rate why do you think that is it's
because they're not actually treating
them they just send them out the door
sorry we can't help you we can't
reconstruct your breast the Medicaid or
Medicare isn't going to pay for that
reconstruction so they don't want those
statistics and you know that's what
trans activists always argued there a 1%
D transition rate but we know there are
so many there's a a Reddit group online
with 50,000 people in the D transition
Forum I believe it's higher than that
now it's higher now this this is the
medical economy this is the dark side of
the medical economy that we all saw
during coid where hospitals wanted to
declare deaths related to coid because
it helped them helped their statistics
and their Federal grant money on the
other side so there's this whole dark
economy that's a word that keeps coming
to mind as I'm listening to you it's
like there's this dark economy the dark
trans economy it's pure arrogance by the
way to say uh this is what equiped the
transition is more common in the early
stage of transition particularly before
surgery the share of trans people who
the transition is unknown which
estimates generally ranging as less than
1% to as many as 8% and then right below
that of course you have the gender GP
link um it which is what which is what
go to the gender CHP links let's see
what that is a trans it's a trans it's a
transactive group but it's it's funny
because some of the major studies on
studying quote unquote D transition uh
don't even include like didn't even
include people who actually um
identified as D transition like there
was the like National transgender survey
that was going around around this time
last year um and by virtue of being a d
transitioner a no longer being part of
that you could not even respond meaning
that they do not they are not even
counting D transitioners in this number
because it was supposed to gauge how
well how many people are there um and
then you don't get an answer of okay
well here's how many D transitioners
there I'm I'm trying to look up the how
just how many people are now in the in
the dend subreddit because even since I
joined it last year it is it is shot up
um is that number public can see that it
is public so it currently has 51k
members on r/d trans um on the dtrans
members 51,000 members 51k members on
r/d and last year it was
37,000 um so it keeps growing I mean it
just keeps growing and there is one
there is one study that they did through
the military where they showed the
number of military personnel that went
on Cross seex hormones and then stopped
coming for their cross- seex hormones
and that's 30% so they're hiding they're
hiding the true numbers because again
it's a cult and they can't have anybody
saying that transition isn't great the
the D subber is what I you know lovingly
refer to as one of the most depressing
places on the internet um the what one
of the most depressing places this the
GP trans no the dtrans subreddit why is
that because there is a we we have each
other but aside from that there is a
total lack of Hope is something you find
in D train communities you have people
who are
suffering so many health problems caused
but as many of them were going through
the darkest time in their lives when
they were pulled into all this thing
many of them were children and you you
see them come out the other end and they
are just broken and desperately
searching for some to hold on to and all
this they are desperately searching for
some hope it gets better and some
hope that it you know that there is help
out there when you have a medical system
that is looking Us in the eyes and
telling us that it doesn't want to help
us that we are just the collateral
damage for a social movement that it
doesn't care how many of us are hurt and
you go to this forum and you read the
stories of the actual people who have
been hurt by this the actual human lives
that have been destroyed by this
treatment and the fact that you just you
just see the activists that are just
like collateral damage and then you have
to ask how many people will be enough
for them to actually care how many cuz
this has like Aon was talking about I
think you even were paying attention to
D transelate before even I IED um and
you just you look at you look at the
numbers shooting up of
people people doing this and you see the
real harm that's caused and you wonder
how many more people are going to be
hurt until you you know give a crap and
notice and maybe even acknowledge that
something has gone wrong here the
horrifying irony of this is so massive
to me right now that these people are
authentically hurting authentically
physically harmed by the treatments and
the drugs drugs and medications and
they're in this dark place which is what
they wanted you to believe you were in
at the start I I never oh you're lost no
one cares about you we do I I never was
truly suicidal until I I detransitioned
and was having to deal with the real
consequences of things like joint pain
so bad I couldn't get out of bed last
winter of things like pelvic pain so bad
I was curled over in the curled up in
the fetal position on the couch until
realizing that may have destroyed my
chance completely of having children
until realizing that parts of my body
are gone that there was nothing wrong
with there was nothing wrong with my
body and it was cut up and having to
come to terms with that and God thank
God I'm in a much better place now and
thank God I have people in my life and
some of the other D transitioners that
like understand what I'm going
through but the medical industry has
essentially created a you know a
destroyed subset of human with lifelong
health issues and lifelong almost trauma
surrounding their body now and kicked
them out the back door because it
doesn't look good on their
stats here here's the thing too I get
phone calls from D
transitioners that are
suicidal the I mean they are literally
suicidal they call me I can't go on I
won't leave my house I don't know what I
am I have removed all my body parts
there's a young man in San Frisco who
called two Fridays ago um he was in a
psychotic break moment when he uh let
them uh remove his
genitals he's
29 he's a straight guy what do I say to
him what do I say to him to help keep
him alive after the doctors have done
this to them and like Luca said and then
they throw him to the curb sorry we
can't help you it was your decision your
autonomous decision we were just the
surgeons we just did what you said to do
I mean these doctors need to be held to
account first Do no harm we do not have
cafeteria
style medical procedures you can't walk
in I mean we shouldn't no one should
walk in and say Hey I want my body parts
removed yeah I I mean I agree and this
is often the only support these kids
have is going to these dtrans forums or
you know there's very little support
because what happens just going back to
the cult is if that person speaks out
online firstly they get canceled they
get bombarded with hate so that's in an
effort to silence them secondly we have
to remember if they're trans most of
their Friendship Circle is likely still
going to be trans or non-binary so for
them to go against their friends is
basically you know they're going to be
Blacklist they're going to be completely
canceled so they have no one to speak to
so that's why they go online they're
speaking with people anonymously and
they can't get that mental health
support and you know they are really
struggling with their mental health what
got you through it you talk about faith
a little bit but what got you through
these days um to be honest it was really
really tough you know I went through
some very dark times you know doing all
these crazy crazy surgeries you know
being left with the scars and it was
really really tough and one of the
things that helped me is kind of having
reminiscence therapy so you kind of
think back to when you were young you
know happy memories so when I was a
little kid I would you know revisit
places I went to like museums or you
know Farms or fields and stuff and
having that reminiscent therapy and I
went to a church I went to as a kid with
my school and I went there and as
rekindling these happy memories and
think you know I was a happy person back
then I've been miserable for about 20
years I need to snap out of it so you
know the faith was and just having that
purpose in life and I thought you know
what what I'm doing is a bad role model
you know I'm taking to Tik Tok I'm trans
I'm sharing this online and stuff and
that could actually hurt someone that
could actually influence someone I I I
want to do two things okay if if we're
already this far along uh I I want to
explain it as well so women who go
through the transition of being a man
okay you explained the surgery what was
it called it's it's a uh what was the
name of it uh phop plasty phop plasty
phop plasty and Tom explained this to me
for the first time yesterday I had no
clue that's how they did it by the way
where they cut a a a you know uh the
horrifying isn't it yeah you and then
and for women uh for men being uh uh
girls where if you don't
constantly you know do certain procedure
it could shut down then you can't pee
then you have you know all these other
things that you could be dealing with
when one wants to go through that
procedure what does that procedure look
like see um when it well when it comes
to the the fale to male identifying one
um from my understanding is it is a
series of surgeries um um that like it
takes a it takes a graph and it leaves
behind a ton of scarring whether it be
on your forearm or I believe on your
thighs in another place I to be honest I
never looked into it because it even
when I was like believed I was trans
completely I was like well that is
absolutely horrifying I don't want that
done um oh
no
um but yeah it's it's it's terrifying it
is these have such high talking about
they have such high complication rates
too you see people going in revision
after revision after revision you see do
you see surgeons that always do like a
terrible job and are known to do a
terrible job of these things in the
community except trans people are shut
down whenever they talk about their
health issues or like these bad surgeons
because they think it's going to look
bad on the rest of the community and
that is why r/d trans is also a place
where like you're hearing about some of
these health issues that transition
causes that get shut down in trans
circles because you might scare someone
and they might not transition if they
knew that if they knew the health
effects in our shocking research on
phalloplasty it says that 40% of the
time they end up incontinent because
they can't because they lose control of
the muscle that we all release when it's
time to pee yeah they also uh bleed they
have a lot of cramps um they have to
constantly go to the toilet and they're
basically in pain for the rest of their
life and then if a man becomes uh with
woman parts you know vagina plasty they
have to use a dilator every single week
for the rest of their life and there was
a case if you know Jazz Jennings who has
the reality TV show you know and her mom
who has transitioned her since she was a
kid and also encourages other parents to
transition their kids she was bragging
about it you know joking about and you
can see this this young kid you know
she's about 18 19 Now jazz Jennings she
is really really suffering with her
mental health you see it on the screen
and it's heartbreaking and the mom is
bragging that oh don't worry you can use
a dilator and that's the reality of what
these uh people that transition have to
go through they're never going to be
able to have these parts functioning
normally they're always going to have
complic they're going to be in pain and
again there's no treatment for that
because these doctors don't want to help
them you know once they've done the
operation you know you're out the door
they don't want you as a statistic as a
D transitioner um also one well one
thing that the phrasing at least that I
liked is um I I have a friend who D
transitioned and he he's referred to
essentially the entire thing
specifically the bottom surgeries as a a
sexual labotomy your function is gone it
is destroyed
um he he's referred to the process of
gender transition as a sexual labotomy
and I think that is a a very a very good
way to phrase it because of the fact
that it is a physical intervention that
is destroying a part of you for what is
a mental health condition and for the
young for for young boys who go on
puberty blockers and then cross- seex
hormones we talked about the lack of
growth but they also never will achieve
um a climax so how do you get how do you
get consent from a 10-year-old how do
you explain if you're going to go on
these puberty blockers and 95% go on to
cross- seex hormones so once you're on
puberty blockers you're going on cross-
seex hormones that you will never
experience a sexual pleasure how do you
explain to a 10-year-old what that means
to give something up there you have no
idea what it is there and this is I
believe forever how do you explain that
how do you define an orgasm um I believe
this was out of the UK one of their
conclusions but there is no there is no
age appropriate way to explain to a
child what the complete loss of their
sexual function as an adult is there's
no age appropriate way to explain it
whether that be you know the boys on
puberty blockers who will never develop
that way whether it be putting young
girls on testosterone to the point where
they have atrophy so bad that it doesn't
matter they're not going to be able to
do things anyway so it's it's terrifying
and there is no there is no age
appropriate way to explain that to a
child and also it's one of those things
where like why are we you know listening
to a young child young teenager young
child's judgment when that when that
that kid is saying they don't want to
have kids of course they don't want to
have kids they're a child themselves
they haven't gotten a chance to grow up
and know what that means and we are
destroying not only their sexual
function but their fertility before they
have even gotten a chance to mature and
get to the point where they can have the
long-term decision making to decide if
that is something they even want
yeah I mean to me it goes back down to
the responsibility the parents and these
parents have issues they they they
sincerely have issues they need to be
diagnosed to see what they're going
through now some of them that are just
worried and they're like oh my God what
do I do I don't want my kid to you know
kill themselves suicide totally get it
they have the fear but there's a certain
responsibility that lies on the kids so
I I want to read this to you okay here's
a here's a list of states where
transgender surgery on minors is banned
we have 50 states States in us only 18
states ban it that means 32 states don't
ban it these are the states that ban it
Alabama Arkansas Arizona Florida Georgia
Idaho Indiana Iowa Kentucky Mississippi
Missouri uh Montana Nebraska South
Dakota Oklahoma South Dakota Tennessee
Utah okay states where transgender s
surgery is approved with parental approv
uh approval New York California
Massachusetts Alaska Illinois Minnesota
New Mexico and California have made
strides protecting access to care for
transgender people states where
transgender surgery is approved without
parental approval let me read this to
you folks states where transgender
surgery is approved without parental
approval okay Oregon allows minors as
young as 15 years old to have sex
reassignment surgery without consent
from their parents California allows
children as long as young as 12 years
old to receive taxpayer funded
transgender treatment and services is
this serious without parental consent
California following states is a list of
states that have a state law that bans
transgender students from participating
in sports consistent with their
transgender identity Bama Arkansas
Florida Georgia Idaho IO Mississippi
Montana South Carolina South Dakota
Tennessee Texas West Virginia you you
keep going through these and you're
sitting there wondering here are some
places where schools can refer to
students by their preferred gender
without notifying parents California
Chicago Public Schools laus DC public
schools Baltimore City Public Schools
San Francisco Unified School District
Portland Public Schools Seattle public
schools in Virginia Fairfax County
Public Schools Montgomery County Public
Schools this is in Maryland you you read
this stuff are these people losing their
minds completely and I and I need I need
to to comment on this because I'm going
to comment it in pieces here let's be
clear almost every Public School in in
the United States is hiding social
transition from the parents even in the
State of Florida they're still doing it
they are doing it in all the red states
too they're doing it in the blue States
they are taught they are trained that
parents uh don't need to know if their
child is gender questioning this is
across the board you can go on to their
websites you can see that they're
claiming that children have um have
privacy rights which they don't have in
the state of Cali californ 12-year-olds
can transition um on the state dime as
long as they run away as long as they're
in foster care than a than a 12-year-old
has power so this is why this is the
whole tie-in to that law that I talked
about why the government wants kids to
be running away because as soon as that
child is 12 they have
self-determination um and same thing in
in uh Oregon and a lawsuit's being filed
against the Oregon law for 15year
olds what you talked about is so
important why California needs to end it
in California because all those red
States those 18 states with bands all of
those children can run away to the state
of
California and get and become a foster
care kid and get these gender
interventions and these trans activist
it's insane you you just said let me
interrupt and just ask one question you
just said California can be the San City
for for Trans runaways Nationwide it is
that law passed last year we are a
sanctuary state so is Minnesota so if a
child from Florida gets a ticket and
runs away to California we take them in
we don't return them back to to Florida
we take them in and we go ahead and
throw them into our foster care system
and let that child um transition that's
why the ballot initiative in California
to stop this is so important it's not
just a California ballot initiative yes
only Californians can vote on it but
everyone in the nation should be um
should be donating to this movement
because again we'll take your kids
Kentucky we'll take your kids from
Tennessee and we will harm them in our
state in California that's what we're
doing and not only that we're going to
advertise Gavin Nome passed a bill that
is going to advertise in all those red
states to come to California if you're a
child who wants to get transitioned you
come to our state we'll take you in and
we'll mutilate you um you will you will
Minnesota is also also a sanctuary state
but you already hear it in these in
these states where where you have the
laws pass protecting children you
already hear it from these activist
parents well we're going to move to
Minnesota we're going to move to
California as if as if the states that
are baned this would would miss them but
um they they will actively move when you
believe in something so um as hard as
these people do you will actually they
will absolutely move just to be able to
do this to their child or the child run
away and you spoke about you mentioned
Oregon in that list of states I believe
it was Oregon or Washington that they
they made it where the state the state
money will cover transition but they
actively excluded any coverage for D
transitioners in their law
wow like act actively it's just a oneway
street isn't it but but you know what it
is you know sometimes people ask me and
they'll say so why' you have that person
on a podcast why' you have this person
on a podcast why' you have that person
on a podcast and why'd you let them talk
because the more they talk if their
argument is pathetic and insane and you
can't see the the hypocrisy in their
argument then it's you you're
responsible as well to understand that
somebody's got gamesmanship on you but
the more they're doing things like this
they're just they're allowing others to
make the argument why they're pathetic
why why they're doing what they're doing
by the way there was a documentary that
was supposed to come out I want to
finish on this here AMC post documentary
featuring D transitioners from theaters
uh uh in face of pressure right this was
I think a few months ago June 19th or
something like that and uh uh Tik Tock
played a pivotal role in Ash ESD Journey
as she explained uh uh no not that one
this is the other one AMC uh uh cancel
screenings of the documentary no way
back yes the reality of gender affirming
care after pressure from activists
including the queer trans project the
transitioner Laura Becker criticized the
decision saying I think it's incredibly
dangerous to set the precedent of
suppressing Free Speech suppressing
viewpoints that basically are just
unpopular or difficult to deal with the
90-minute film features D transitioner
stories and insites from experts
examining the risks and long-term
implications of gender affirming
medication AMC attributed the
cancellation to poor ticket sales but
deplorable films the dist Distribution
Company defended the documentary noting
that those opposing it had not seen the
film before taking actions to silence it
so actually about this about this film
um I did a panel at a screening of it in
LA but I also went to a film festival in
Iowa to represent the director um and
talk about it and answer questions and
Laura the quote from Laura that you just
read out is completely right that it is
alarming that we are you know silen
essentially what is an unpopular opinion
the film is I'm going to be real when
you watch it it's like it's one of those
things where you watch it and you're
like this this is what people are upset
about because it's just presenting the
other side of just how bad things have
gotten and it's presenting D
transitioners stories and it it has
Professionals in it it has doctors in it
it has you know it has the people that
are doing the quotequote science these
people claim to care so much about um it
has them and it has them pointing out
some truths that yes they are
uncomfortable but they need to be said
because kids are being hurt and it was
one of those things
where you know um they they canceled it
and they can say it's because of poor
ticket sales but it's not true it's not
true I know the director I know who
wrote it I know her her whole story um
and she's a Democrat too um and uh yeah
they're canceling us left and right um
this is this is the way it is um there's
a multitude of films that been been out
there but this one was was finally
getting distribution and the trans
activist shut it down remember 60
Minutes about two years ago or three
years ago where the D transitioners went
on um they cut that that programming too
they don't want to hear the other side
this is the cult mentality the New York
Times won't print my name they've
interviewed me countless times they
won't they won't print the other side
they won't print the truth can't have
somebody Google you they might find out
right I mean it is it it's hiding the
best kept secret right if if they are so
proud of what they're doing why why are
they afraid of listening to the other
side I mean you see the The Washington
Post they they won't use the word d
transitioner they won't they won't write
about us they won't write about the
parents who are pulling their kids out
they won't write about the parents who
are losing custody of their kids because
they won't call their daughter a boy or
their son a girl there's complete
silence on this so I appreciate you
having this podcast but there are
thousands of us tens of thousands of us
out there and they're ignoring us and
pretending it's not happening well I I
think I think the most important thing
when when you said you know what do they
do when you're looking at this uh what
was the website Reddit you said what
everybody's writing stuff and and and
what's missing to me uh uh there's a few
things in a situation like that one you
need love and support like a community
you're part of where at least you feel
like man there's other people that are
going through what I'm going through two
you need Faith cuz there's no one can do
anything man the only thing you can rely
on is some a higher power to have faith
in that's going to allow you to go
through that process three you need
Fighters that are going to fight for you
like yourself that are doing what
they're doing and smart folks that are
coming around that are willing to write
bills the average person is like write a
bill how do I write a bill well this is
why you need folks like you that are
willing to do that and and stand up you
know and and then last but not least you
know everybody lives a weird life man if
you believe in God God you know
sometimes chooses you to play a role of
a you know a person that's going to
share their message and Inspire others
that they're going through tough times
and show strength and sometimes you know
life is a very weird life that we we get
taken advantage of at times and those
who can stand up and stay strong in that
uh end up inspiring others to also go
through the challenge and times because
they say if he can do it if she can do
it I can as well I applaud you Luca for
coming here and sharing your story
applaud you a lot uh really and the
reason why I say that not that it's a
competition like I applaud you more than
others you're 21 you know it's like for
some of us I mean I heard you even say I
think you're a child to you're 25 years
old because you're still developing
you're still at that 21 age right some
of the some of the more prominent D
transitioners they transitioned as
adults when they were going through it
you know whether that be abuse all Navy
SEAL that that's another storyed out to
me we were going to have them on today
as well and you know yeah I'm I'm I'm
with you so here's here's what I want to
do at we're at the end of the podcast uh
a couple things if you have any
questions for ali uh or Aaron you can
find them on mck ask questions parents
ask as many questions as possible
specifically from Arin because she's in
this she can give you her perspective
Ali for someone that's going through it
you can also visit the website uh from a
inside on Pro protect kids californiaca
protect kids ca.com Ali has a book that
came out gender Madness the L will link
will also be below for you to order it
and uh aside from that my biggest
recommendation to everybody share this
content talk about it with your kids
talk about it with your spouse talk
about it with your siblings talk about
it with your family environment uh get
more these types of conversations going
and if you're running another big
podcast and you got kids you're worried
about it why don't you invite them as
well to come and start talking about
these things until mainstream has no
choice but to have to talk about about
it we're seeing right now podcasters are
starting to have more power than
mainstream anyways you know the days of
mainstreamers having that Monopoly are
behind us there's many ways to get the
message out once again thank you so much
for coming out and sharing your story
with everybody appreciate you guys thank
you thank you take care everybody bye-
bye
bye-bye